i gotta show you guys so okay so here's
what happened so i was
watching my son play
and i was in one of these moments where
i caught myself just kind of watching
him play
and not only
did my heart feel full my heart just
felt like it ate
brunch and breakfast do you know what i
mean just full of [ __ ]
like my heart got up early had breakfast
and it was like you know what i'll meet
the friends for brunch too
and ate brunch too and just it felt like
it was swelling
you understand like i had eggs in there
and then i all also had
a little bit of a [ __ ] i had some
athletes buried on a salad you know
and it was just swell as [ __ ] i felt
love
and the cool thing about it was
sometimes you feel love
when you're looking at either your
partner or your mom and your dad or your
son or your daughter whoever the [ __ ] it
is
and then sometimes you feel love and you
think about
how you feel the love right you process
it
you realize wow i'm a human or as neil
degrasse tyson would say
your billions of dust particles billions
and billions of dust particles and
billions of years
it took billions of years to to say to
do to make you
and that's how you exist on these
billions of years when wolves became
dogs and dogs games and then billions of
billions and billions and billions of
years
billions of particles of dust and
particles
um and and i
felt human as [ __ ] i felt so human i
felt jackson human
but i felt human okay and i was looking
at my son and i was like
wow we're all billions of specks of dust
and my heart seems
full of billions i went to brunch and i
ate billions of billions of eggs and
then i went to
and then i had breakfast before and i
realized i had billions and billions
billions of sun-dried tomatoes and
billions and billions of eggs
but i had billions and billions of
particles of love and um
and i was looking at him and i realized
that not only did i
feel that way but i was laying and i was
comfortable as [ __ ] and i was
relaxed for the first time in a very
long time
i you know what i was i
was do you understand it's like when
those
chicks think they're [ __ ] creative by
saying like i'm human
being right like it's like saying i'm
not business man
i'm a businessman i'm not a human being
i'm a human
being
and um i fought it i'm lactose
and um so i was just being i was a human
being and i realized i was smiling
and the interesting thing about that was
it was a
i didn't know i was smiling you know
sometimes hey get together for a picture
and you just pose and you're like here
comes a smile
or you're having a good time and you're
like [ __ ] is a good time
and you're laughing and you're like wow
i'm laughing real hard this is awesome
but every now and then it doesn't happen
often you have a smile
and you actually check in with your body
right you check in like it's the dmv
you just go to the front desk in your
head and you're like hey
i'm smiling aren't i and the rest of
your body is like
yup so i'm like what an
interesting thing i don't
normally feel this way or check in with
my body
and experience this in this way
and i'm holding my phone as i do this
so i'm like you know what i could do i
could easily just swipe my phone to the
side
and have the picture the camera come up
which a lot of people don't know
kristen doesn't know wifey she has no
idea you can do this and i tell her this
all the time and i hand her my phone and
i say take a picture of me and my son
and she says what's your code and i say
you don't need a code just swipe it to
the side
and she says you do it and then i got to
do it and by then i'm pissed off and the
moment's over
so i know this and since i'm already
checked in and i'm smiling and i realize
it's a genuine smile and i've never
really seen myself
give a genuine smile coupled with the
information that i could just slide this
camera over
and it's already on selfie mode because
your boy
he's conceded and he takes lots of
selfies
so i slide it to the side and i got this
and i also know guess what i also know
you can take a picture by just pressing
the side button on your iphone so you
don't have to guess where the button is
in the [ __ ] thing
so i'm not [ __ ] so i'm just here i slide
it over and i take a picture in selfie
mode by using the side of the button
to see what i look like
with a pure 100 percent
genuine smile this is
not a joke at all
at all this is not a joke
but this is the picture of
me 100 genuinely
dripping with purity smiling
it looks like i'm daniel day-lewis in my
left foot
it looks like i can't move my body
at all except for my left foot
and the only thing i can say that is
like intelligible is like oatmeal like
that you know what i mean like that's
what i want
dude i don't know how i look so [ __ ]
up
and i'm not making i'm not like doing
this this isn't a joke
my smile looks so [ __ ] bad
if my kid were to have looked at me like
even though i was looking at him if he
had looked at me
it would have just he would have been
like what the [ __ ] we got to get dad to
the hospital
i'm trying to find this picture right
now so i could send it to
everybody in the
just [ __ ] insane
uh it's so bad i'm looking at i'm trying
to describe
it to the people who listen um i look
like i'm like you know what i look like
actually i
look like i'm thinking
i look like i'm you know what i'm i look
like i look like a racist guy
that's watching the race he hates
win a bunch of money at poker
and i'm just like these [ __ ]
persians like that's how i
that's how i look
this [ __ ] that's my
smile that's my genuine smile watching
my son play and be happy dude
i i looked at the phone i was like oh my
god dude i [ __ ]
don't get it
i don't get it
so i got to get a new smile one time
when i was younger my mom said you
should walk different
oh it hurt me to my core
she said you need a cool walk oh but
that hurt me to my
core
you should walk different i said why she
said i don't know you know how some guys
walk cool
oh it hurt me to my
car i was
16 how could you do it mom
you need a new walk never forgot it
think about it too much
my mom doesn't like the way i walk
that's bad it's bad to say to your son
all good dude you know what i need that
walk i need that [ __ ]
beginning of the [ __ ] song
[Music]
with my [ __ ] collar so high it's
scraping ceilings